We're here at the San Francisco trolley station.
Now, the trolleys in San Francisco have a lot of mass.
The hills in San Francisco are quite steep.
In order to keep a decent pace going up these hills,
these trolleys need to have a lot of power.
In this problem, you're going to make some calculations involving
the power of a San Francisco trolley.
So, my question is if you have a cable car with a mass of 2000 kg
on a hill inclined at 10 degrees and it needs to keep moving up
at a constant pace of 25 kg per hour, what is the necessary power?
Now, there's two ways to solve this problem.
One involves using an equation that you learned in one of the problem sets,
and actually this would be a nice, simple, easy way to solve it.
The other would require a little bit more work and would involve the definition
of power that you learned in class.
You can enter your answer here in watts.